we've gotten showrunner we've got a new
doctor what else can we change now
despite that intro I don't want to seem
like I want everything to change about
Doctor Who I loved our - I don't want a
ton of massive overhauls there's a lot
of stuff that obviously should stay the
same but there are a number of patterns
that have existed in Doctor Who since it
came back with series one in the ninth
doctor Christopher Eccleston that I
would like to see broken and I am hoping
that Chris Chibnall will not continue
these patterns started by Davies and
continued by Moffat so here are my list
of five patterns that I want to see
Doctor Who break starting with series 11
we'll start with number 5 pretty much
only classic era villains are recurring
at this point what are the villains who
keep showing up over and over and over
again Daleks Cybermen the master now
we've had a few others besides that the
Angels came back a little bit but
unfortunately they kind of got run into
the ground we have the silence briefly
but a much are that wrapped up well but
honestly at this point we need to have
the big gun to tongue return oh I didn't
see that coming be something other than
these things that keep coming back over
and over and over again I would like for
a big holy crap moment to be something
like the return of anthony Stewart head
as mr. fynch
imagine imagine if he had shown up
facing down Capaldi how awesome would
that have been there's any number of
those that could be brought back again
or heck make some new bills and have
them start reappearing now this is not
me saying get rid of the old villains I
know we can't especially in the case of
the Daleks I'm well aware of the
agreement with Terry Nations of state
that they have to use them in some
capacity every year but we keep
defaulting back to these guys over and
over and over again in terms of trying
to up the stakes and having like a big
villain reveal moment when honestly I
think it would be nice to cultivate some
more stuff
I love the doctor who goes back and
refers to the old stuff but you can't
keep banking on nostalgia all the time
you've got to give us some new stuff and
make the new stuff
matter and make us care about it and I
feel like in terms of villains they kind
of stop trying and they just keep going
back to these set the same well again
and again and again again I got this one
right number five and list because it's
the least solid pattern the show has
broken it from it a couple of times like
I said angels silence but even those
were kind of short-lived at the end of
the day and I think the show just needs
what the show needs a bigger pool of
recurring villains and a bigger
percentage of that pool needs to be from
modern Doctor Who not all old stuff if
for no other reason then it becomes too
predictable I'm not going to say I'm not
still waiting for Omega to show up but
you would really surprise me if you
brought back one of the villains that
was introduced it knew who I'd be way
more thrown off by that and that would
be so much more unexpected and
potentially exciting than any old
villain you would care to bring back
number four
stop demystifying Gallifrey now this is
one that's really infuriating for me
that the new show does because this was
a problem with the old show when doctor
who started the Time Lord pack we didn't
even know what the race was called for
years and the end we didn't know what
the planet they were from was called
first several years past that the
information we had about the time was
initially was really really sparse and
then starting in Tom Baker's era and
then snowballing from there we started
to get more and more and more
information about them and the more
information we got about the Time Lords
the less interesting they became and
unfortunately by extension the less
interesting the doctor became because we
knew too much about the culture he came
from and the doctor should have a
certain air of alienness and mystery but
the more we understood about that that
culture the less alien he felt now I
think Russell T Davies made a very wise
choice with the insertion of the time
war and Gallifrey is gone so it
reassured all the mystery for anybody
coming in is like wow what is this lent
if man will never know we give these
little ideas and you know we got little
glimpses of it when the master came back
okay and then even when the doctor saved
Gallifrey in the day of the doctor I was
still kind of okay with it because he
saved it from just
yeah but it wasn't suddenly restored he
still didn't have it there I was like oh
so like him pursuing Gallifrey that can
be a very long-term goal that they then
wrapped up an incredibly haphazard way
in hell bent in that episode this is
another thing onto the pile of things
that I don't like about how bed but we
go there and there's all these Gallifrey
uns hanging around looking like Little
House on the Prairie in a barn that
eliminates so much mystery about these
about this race and this planet stop
showing us this stuff I honestly do not
think there's a great deal of narrative
use to be mined out of the Time Lords
anymore at this point you've got your
Wow
punch of bringing them back and you got
your kind of triumphant moment of him
saving the planet so they didn't all die
I don't think there's much more to be
milked out of this that is not going to
cause the problem that we got in the
classic era which is that we just know
too much and ultimately that is an
equation that doesn't balance the longer
the more we get the less interesting it
is stop cut it off no more number 3
everybody lives now despite that
specific moment being shot by
Christopher Eccleston being one of my
favorite moments of Doctor Who ever
still to this day it happens way too
often and I'm not necessarily talking
about incidental characters and you know
fodder in episodes I think we still get
enough of that and I would rather that
we had more developed additional
characters out of them we were killing
them left and right but the classic
series had a decent body count and at
this point we need more deaths that
means something to us
part of the thing about the older series
was because these shows were these four
six sometimes eight part or longer
series that went on for a total of two
for even longer number of hours even the
characters that were introduced
pacifically for those stories and
weren't you know the companions or
whatnot we had when the sword was done
well we had the chance to get to know
them so much better so if they died it
really had it had the amount of impact
and that is what I'm talking about
the show has done this a couple of times
but it has a tendency to backtrack on it
and I'm going to come back to that but
every now and then we get something like
the death of Osgoode
or you know a companion will die again
I'm going to come back to that but but
by-and-large true meaningful deaths of
characters don't happen often enough not
for how long the show has been running
and again I'm not flat-out asking for a
higher body count but I think mainly I'm
looking for fewer miraculous saves and I
kind of touched on this in an earlier
video when I mentioned the pattern that
has gone on with the companions because
every single companion of new Doctor Who
whether they left the TARDIS willingly
whether they were forced out by
circumstances whether they died has come
back and had some additional moment on
top of that the show keeps doing death
and then undoing it and that has to stop
now I'm not criticizing each individual
insist this happened sometimes work
sometimes it didn't but let's look at
the pattern Rose trots in another
dimension wonderful touching
heartbreaking she comes back Martha
leaves the TARDIS of her own volition
out of a moment that very much speaks to
the strength of her character and is
then brought back and does nothing
particularly significant Donna
heartbreaking crushing moment and then
she comes back kind of Amy sent to the
bath without her life dies we still get
this one last note this hallucination
between her and Matt Smith Clara Oh God
hell-bent again but oh she had a
fantastic send-off and face the Raven we
saw the doctor grieve and mourn in
Heaven Sent and then he'll Ben just
undid all of it and now bill again
converted to a Cyberman basically killed
but gets this last-minute reprieve
we had it with River first time you see
her she dies but the consciousness is
saved what I'm asking for when I say
stop doing everybody lives is let death
happen and let it mean something the
doctor can't save
every one and when he does any potential
impact that any individual death of a
character has is gone it becomes the
problem that comic books have there was
an old saying with comic book readers
that nobody stays dead except for Bucky
Uncle Ben and Jason Todd they don't say
that anymore you know why because two
out of three of those things came back
to life death has no meaning in comic
books because it never sticks and doctor
who is coming dangerously close to doing
the same thing at this point again I'm
not saying that it should suddenly up
the body count start killing on people
I'm just saying when the decision is
made to have a character die keep them
dead let it be sad we can take it
number two the companion template again
something I've talked about before now
this one actually I'm not going to say
I'm torn on but I'm going to with
slightly just stuff that I've said
before because I've gone on record
multiple times before that the current
companion template is young attractive
human female from modern earth now can't
decide if we need to break from the
female or not I've certainly said in the
past please give us a male companion I
would love that at this point I'm a
little iffy on it and this is the one
part of this particular video where I'm
going to bring up the fact that the
doctor is going to be a woman in series
11 for however long Jodie Whittaker
plays the part now the obvious thing to
do in order to Sofia reticle II maintain
some kind of balance would be to say
well just make the companion a man I'm
not sure if I want that because I would
like to think that the decision to make
the doctor woman is rooted in a very
strong performance from her and some
genuine possibilities to be mined from
that change but I don't want to see it
dictate everything else about the show
where you go oh well the doctor is a
woman so now we do the companion as a
man that would feel like much more of a
jerk reaction to this initial decision
that you made than anything else so I'm
not sure if I want that or not so at
first what I'm going to say I'll be okay
with the Companions still being a woman
again but what I'm done with is for the
companion to be a human from
contemporary
earth please enough look if you don't
want to go so bonkers is to have the
companion be an alien at the very least
can it be a person out of time a person
from the past a person from the future
they can still be human they can still
be from Earth just do something to break
this template I mean why do they have to
be from modern day earth anyways well I
know why because it allows them to set
more stories in modern day earth because
that's cheaper and that's a budgetary
concern but it's really resulted in an
incredibly say me string of companions
and no I'm not saying all companions are
identical they each have their own
flavor they've each brought something
but I want just a basic fundamental
break from this template and since I
can't really make up my mind on whether
or not I still want to no longer have a
female companion I am going to put my
foot down please just don't let them be
from modern-day earth there's no reason
not a companion from the past couldn't
wrap their head around this stuff enough
to travel the doctor it happened before
Jamie was the second doctor you one of
my favorite companions ever and a
companion from the future should have an
even easier time than someone from
modern day would be so just please Chris
Chibnall please break this one and the
number one pattern that I need Doctor
Who to break from is the mystery box
every single series of new doctor who
has had an element of the mystery box
and by the mystery box I mean something
that is introduced early on into the
series that then recurs at various
intervals as the series goes along and
is unexplained and maybe we get pieces
explaining it as we go maybe it only
gets explained in like the last episode
or in the setup for the finale or
whatever but it's something that they
string on going don't you want to know
what this is and I'll break it down for
you
series one it was bad wolf series - it
was Torchwood series 3 it was John Saxon
series 4 it was the reappearances of ros
series 5 the cracks in time series 6
actually series 6 almost broke from it
because that started with whoa we just
saw the doctor die how do we prevent
this from happening but they still threw
a mystery box ailment and because the
question was who's in the astronaut
outfit series seven was the impossible
girl
series eight was Missy series nine was
the hybrid and of course series ten was
the vault II nuff already now part of
this problem is that this feeds back
into my first one which is that more
often than not what is behind the
mystery boxes is one of those recurring
villains again that keeps happening over
and over again but I'm not even going to
necessarily say that that specifically
is the issue but just this pattern of
here's this thing we're going to string
you along for the entirety of the series
until we feel like revealing to you
please stop and is become a distraction
at this point and honestly I was tired
of it back in the Davies era so in fact
that Moffat felt the need to continue it
as well has really frustrated me and
again each individual instance and this
is true of all these patterns that I've
talked about each individual instance of
this thing occurring in the show may
have been good may have even been great
but it's the fact that it keeps
happening over and over and over again
and it's the repetition and Doctor Who
should not become this repetitive and
this formulaic that needs to get shaken
up to some degree not necessarily in
like a massive let's change with Doctor
Who is but there's no reason for any of
these patterns that I've listed to keep
being the case over and over and over
again now in terms of the mystery boxes
oh really you want a really simple
template to break from do the Buffy the
Vampire Slayer model where you make it
clear fairly early on who the villain is
and just have them keep reappearing and
so we're tracking them rather than some
vague mystery that you're withholding
the answer or heck don't even do it
overarching for a series just have it be
a bunch of completely self-contained
things again not saying overarching
can't work but just the patterns need to
get shaken up because regardless of what
anyone says about this will kill Doctor
Who this will kill Doctor Who Moffat
killed it Jodie Whittaker is going to
like no repetition staleness that will
kill Doctor Who and the narrative
structure of the show needs to break
from these patterns I'm not saying we
need to smash all the toys but we need
to find different ways to play with them
than we have been so those are my
thoughts on five patterns that have been
recurring in new who that I think need
to stop what are your thoughts on these
do you have any patterns that you
noticed over the course of new whoo that
you're kind of tired of and would like
to see drops whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher I am also one half
of the punch like a girl podcast also
available on iTunes and stitcher until
next time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]